ha hey folks you know you want to talk
about we know what we want to talk about
it's fallout 4 this is peripheral look
at it here it's the pip-boy edition of
fallout 4 right right here are you dumb
and spend 120 dollars on this like your
me you're one of those people they think
this is Ben's I think I think did you
buy the pit boy Dino now Japan okay I'm
alone here there's someone else in the
offices I'm sure but it looks schools
right here look is it worth a hundred
dollars have you put it on have you try
anything worthwhile yes a lot of things
about her daughter's he watched gamespot
com you could see Danny and I shelf is
handed to it and realize it opens it
does sir ok so I'm biased cuz I've
already spent my money on this it's on
the wrong hand but it's upside down but
don't worry about it I'm glad you let me
correct let me I want I want your
opinion what do you think about it build
quality why don't we staying what a bill
called this is actually really nice like
this is a sturdier thing that I would
have thought I mean it's a hundred
dollars I if this works exchange money
though oh the knobs move with the game
all that's why I'm so scared to my knock
this over on tomato Oh another does this
not work today oh there we go okay it
lights up you put your phone in yeah
it'll have an app which will connect up
to the video game which is out at some
stage in the future yeah we don't know
no and if we did we couldn't tell you
and then you can you can play the video
game apparently with this on you know
it's nice and light as well do you think
yeah it's not it's not heavy it feels
pretty nurse velcro this feels like a
kind of metal that's the only metal
thing on it yeah in fact the one thing
about the build quality I wasn't so sure
is that we had a bit of trouble opening
it up to the phone yeah if you're
playing a try again let's see okay so we
had to push it oh no I'm gonna break
this yeah need to push it we had to push
it up like this right here comes out
yeah was damaged yeah it's out and it
can spin so many lines of phones it can
fit this kind of you aware that this
goes down yeah I think that's what you
do to pull it up or something so it
feels kind of plasticky and when you're
trying to like fit it back in it doesn't
like click oh yeah yeah yeahs a me see
if I can it's like
it's so like you have I'm afraid to
break it yeah cuz it's like that looks
like you can't pop it up so that's where
the phone go but when you put it back
down again it see it kind of catches
this yeah weird part so you have to like
lift it up and talk what I'm saying is
if you're taking this thing off and
putting it on again over and over yeah
good cuz look if I time force this down
or like who does that as a fashion
accessory yet this is how I would want
to use my flag I really got to you kind
of you kind of push it down and release
the dolly it seemed unstylish to get one
of those hip holsters but at the same
time like I don't like keeping my phone
in my pocket and you know SmartWatch I
have a SmartWatch here it's too small
like I can't do anything with this is
useless this is my phone on my wrist
that's amazing me know smartwatches are
all about peacocking right so what's
like the ultimate smartphone peacock
it's the neck yeah this looks dumb
nobody can not see that this does look
dumb but imagine if I was inside I'm
like oh it's not it just Falls so I have
no idea if we're like the real test is
gonna be how yeah because blizzard I've
now signup blizzard Bethesda have now
it'll be the third out they've launched
this year yeah cuz they align there's a
new app that just came out today follow
chat they'll let you chat download it no
I did can someone else please don't as
well so the not getting emojis to beat
yourself and see you can at least in the
the Android version of it you can open
it up and then send those icons to other
two other services so you use it in work
we use slack we do you can use send
those gifts it's like oh really follow
check right now my question for you
Danny is when the game comes out are you
gonna be wearing this 24 7 i'm gonna
give it a go first way when i'm playing
the game 24 70 should see how long you
can go wearing this thing oh I'll wait
go on the morning and it'll be like
broken underneath my waist look like
will you take it off while you sleep in
your shower okay but I'll be interesting
I can't wait to see what its gonna be
like actually like playing ortak foreign
long-dated because vol it's a game you
can easily played 156 m yeah you're lost
in it yeah it seems like you could get
like we don't know how long I'm gonna
buy some pot a free coming yeah it for
its previous form when you play fallout
three you get dudes we get lost in it
right yeah so presumably if you're to
play for four
you would get lost in it for a while I
make your hand go I think I would be
afraid that it would be cutting off
circulation to my hand which could have
positive benefits as well but when a
stranger y-yeah the shank going for the
stranger but it's like about also we did
it cut off circulation weight varies
screaming line so if this isn't of
course you don't actually up to wear
this you can just it can be yeah
collectible thing a decorative piece if
it comes with a stands that's in there
which yeah I do you want you to take the
stand what but it's not the only dump
all right thing for our merchandising
today no god damn it and this controller
oh boy is available or not really
available anymore which cost me was
available for about 24 hours yeah it was
it was so pretty quick um yeah just cost
75 nobody saw it only saw it forward
it's got 75 bucks before shipping I'm
not really sure what his little
controllers also are pretty pricey for
fifty dollars because next one so this
takes a headset just any regular head
say it does it has a new button as a
button that lets you mute yeah and it
lights up when it's working I just you
know this isn't like a sponsored thing
we're just showing this off so you can
decide if you want to buy this
controller with its 10 foot USB cable
for people who have been who have like
living in the wasteland far away from it
from the television television I'd buy
this for that table that's an awesome
cable you want a cheap USB cable with a
free controller 10 10 10 feet it's it's
wired only as well and you can't see it
but the buttons are also somewhat
customized yes or fall out so when you
press left there's a controller button
when you press right there's a little
person a person yes it's kind of good so
it feels alright it's like it doesn't go
grip to it no PlayStation controller no
no PlayStation version yeah I think I
kind of feel like the fact that this is
wired as well it means they're too it's
a pc controller you know what i mean
like hey it'll work at the box wood
windows 10 or windows seven or eight i
think as well and there's a now a
wireless adapter for xbox one controller
eckrich it's $25 i think much i'm not
sure afford this 11 yeah so there you go
this feels nice that's all your fun I
think I can't wait to eventually play
the video game and then we can talk
about it yeah and but until then you get
to
look at these wonderful things and I can
imagine yeah what it would be like oh we
can we can show them to you as viewers
to see if you want to purchase them as
well but I sure can wait I fought it you
can't purchase either of those can you
like this is just all aftermarket sim
you're basically saying hey you should
go out and buy these four thousand
dollars I thought yeah they did a second
run in the pit boys I would be surprised
if they did well they did like a third
uh no that was went over multiple times
and sold out each time there only way to
get these things now is by sorry so I
don't really talk about fallout 4 stuff
and this is the only way we're able to
do it so there's no choice this is the
thing hey on a completely different note
what did you play over the weekends I
could danica so yummy did you uh yeah I
played The Witcher 3 one of many great
games that came out in 2015 all right